the largest demonstrations in the
history of belarus have taken place on
recent sundays and tomorrow will be no
exception
hundreds of thousands are expected in
the capital city of minsk to protest the
re-election earlier this month of the
nation's strongman president
after a vote widely seen as corrupt but
protesters know they are risking
arrest or even worse fate chris livesay
has the update
good morning demonstrations in belarus
show no sign of slowing down and that's
despite
a violent government crackdown several
demonstrators have died
and the body of one of them was found
right here
in these woods
for more than a week no one heard a word
from nikita krifsov
then the 28 year old's body was found in
this wooded area in minsk
hanging from a tree officially a suicide
police say there was no foul play at
work but
no one we've spoken to here believes
that
i'm 100 percent certain police killed
him says his friend alexander novik
if they can do it to him they can do it
to anyone
in an unprecedented display of
resistance for more than two weeks
young and old have been demanding
president alexander lukashenko
step down after elections widely seen as
rigged the police response has been
savage at least three protesters died
from their injuries
president lucas had tried to scare all
of these people into staying home
but it's clearly backfired despite
beating them bludgeoning them and
even torturing them today they've given
up
their fear and traded it in for anger
and for courage
anger and courage from nikita krifsall
days before he went missing
seen here staring down riot police and
holding up the opposition flag of
belarus
as one officer records the identities of
protesters
he's known as europe's last dictator an
image he relishes
at one recent protest as his helicopter
circled above an estimated
250 000 demonstrators he said
they flee like rats then descended
wearing a bulletproof vest
and brandishing an assault rifle as he
applauded his security forces
they forced opposition leader svetlana
tikanovskaya
into exile in neighboring lithuania
i believe in our people and i'm sure
that
we will not lose this moment what's
going to happen to you
remains in belarus our voice cannot be
ignored she told me
everything will be fine with me shortly
thereafter
she was detained and sentenced to 10
days in prison for unauthorized protests
long-lived belarus they shout a call to
action
despite ongoing threats from the
president says andre dimitriev
an opposition candidate if you could say
one thing to president lukashenko right
now what would it be
please leave us a somber scene at the
funeral and a grim one here in these
woods where that young protester's body
was
found the protesters say that was an act
to intimidate them but that in the end
only made them stronger for cbs this
morning saturday chris livesay minsk
belarus